die party hat den schweden nie ganz
aufgehört europa saß im lockdown doch
schwedens regierung ließ die leinen
locker
wir waren nicht groß eingeschlossen
haben höchstens im home office arbeiten
müssen jetzt gehen alle wieder raus und
benehmen sich da fast wie 2009 10 aber
schweden zahlt einen hohen preis für den
umgang mit corona auf den friedhöfen
liegen im verhältnis vier mal so viele
krone opfer wie in deutschland manche
traf es besonders hart
hier liegt der cousin meines vaters
begraben und hier ist das grab vom sohn
unseres pastors
jetzt testen sie ob der schwäbische weg
doch zu ausreichender immunität gegen
korona führt ist die strategie der
schweden für die ganz europa sie
verurteilt doch die richtige vor allem
stimmt es überhaupt nicht mit dem
selbstbild der schweden über einen das
ist glaube die größte kränkung die da
drinnen
der sommer ist gekommen in salza baden
in der provinz stockholm für einen
moment macht er vergessen dass auch
schweben noch immer leidet unter der
korona krise jessica und ihre familie
gehörten zu den ersten im land die sich
mit dem neuartigen virus infiziert
hatten
sie glauben nicht dass schweden schon
über den berg ist
nein es wird eine zweite welle kommt das
ist hier noch nicht vorbei das ist in
schweden wie überall corona hatte sich
hier draußen 20 autominuten entfernt von
stockholm früh erreicht die familie ist
wieder gesund gilt jetzt als immun
trotzdem hat sich ihr leben verändert
jessica schult führungskräfte in
unternehmen
doch die haben gerade kaum bedarf was
bleibt erledigt sie per video konferenz
aus dem homeoffice jetzt hat sie viel
mehr zeit für die kinder und für
spaziergänge ans meer
es war jemand frederik der das virus
mitte märz ins haus gebracht hatte er
hatte es sich wohl bei freunden
eingefangen die zum skifahren in italien
waren und keinerlei symptome zeigten als
er sich mit ihnen traf
das war an einem donnerstagnachmittag
innerhalb weniger stunden habe ich
richtig hohes fieber bekommen
dann lag ich acht oder neun tage mit 40
grad fieber im bett
das war sehr anstrengend husten musste
ich kaum hatte aber kopfweh und starke
schmerzen überall meine frau musste sich
um mich und die kinder können
kinder aus kranken familien sondern in
schweden weiter zur schule gehen solange
sie keine symptome der krankheit zeigen
doch andere eltern verlangten dass
jessica die drei nicht mehr in den
unterricht schicken
so blieben alle daheim leben dass wir
einen infektionsherd darstellen der
andere krank machen könnte und man
plötzlich zu einem sozialen paria wird
war gruselig und unangenehm dass andere
vor uns angst sobald es um ihre familien
geht halten die schweden offenbar wenig
vom prinzip der freiwilligkeit dass
sonst die pandemie maßnahmen prägt die
sind eher empfehlungen denen aber
weitgehend gefolgt wird
stockholm wirkt leer viele haben ihre
arbeit ins home office verlegt
freiwillig denn er will einen strikten
lockdown wie in den nachbarländern
vermeiden
anders tech nel schwedens oberster lotse
durch die pandemie hat das ziel dass
sich viele mit dem virus infizieren
je mehr immun werden desto langsamer
breitet sich das virus aus das
bestreitet niemand und es sind schon
viele immun geworden
man wird definitiv immun dagegen aber
ganz verschwinden wird die krankheit
nicht weil er das öffentliche leben nie
ganz ab wirkte für eine titels vorgehen
weltweit beachtung im land wächst aber
auch die kritik den schweden zahlt einen
hohen preis
im verhältnis zur bevölkerungszahl
sterben hier viermal so viele menschen
mit carola wie in deutschland vor allem
ältere menschen in engen einwanderer
führte
auch miri gori trauert um ihren vater
trotz eindeutiger symptome wurde der
syrer nicht getestet sondern vom arzt
nach hause geschickt mit hustensaft und
antibiotikum
als er tage später doch ins krankenhaus
kamen war es zu spät
andere länder haben irland geschlossen
und nicht mit ihren bürgern
experimentiert mein vater war ein
experiment denn hier sagen sie einige
immunsysteme vertragen das virus anderen
nicht das immunsystem meines vaters hat
den kampf verloren ganz klar in ihrem
stadtteil haben sich viele infiziert vor
allem im gottesdienst auf diesem
friedhof frische gräber dicht an dicht
in diesem grab liegt ein ehepaar das
sich mit kuwait angesteckt hatte sie
waren in der gleichen kirche wie mein
vater
und hier sind noch mehr leute die an dem
virus gestorben sind
hier ist der cousin meines vaters und
hier ist der sohn unseres pastors
die gebürtige syrerin ist überzeugt in
einem anderen land würde ihr vater
vielleicht noch leben
wissenschaftler aber warnen schweden
könnte jetzt das durchmachen was andere
noch bevorstehen könnte mittelfristig
die gesundheits rendite einfahren für
den kurs der herdenimmunität wenn wir
herdenimmunität aufbauen könnten unsere
opferzahlen im internationalen vergleich
am ende nicht höher sondern sogar
niedriger sein denn einen impfstoff wird
es frühestens um weihnachten herum geben
und ich glaube die zweite welle trifft
uns viel früher das konzept der
herdenimmunität ist unter schwedens
wissenschaftlern allerdings umstritten
ich glaube das virus ist viel tödlicher
aber weniger ansteckend als wir noch im
märz gedacht haben gehen wir also davon
aus dass es sich nicht so schnell
verbreitet gedacht und dass die
krankheit schlimmer verläuft und
tödlicher ist ist das konzept der
herdenimmunität keine gute strategie
nach der schweden solle stattdessen mehr
testen
die infizierten und ihre kontaktpersonen
isolieren und sollte die krankheit
ausbrechen die patienten behandeln
immerhin vor allem private medizin
dienstleister wie grün so wird sie das
test geschäft eingestiegen
also die schwedische regierung hat ein
ziel ausgegeben 100.000 tests pro woche
durchzuführen hat es aber
organisatorisch bislang mit den eigenen
kapazitäten nicht geschafft diese tests
tatsächlich umzusetzen
wir haben die kapazitäten aufgebaut und
können im prinzip da jetzt helfen um
diese zahl zu erreichen
damit könnte man vermeiden dass sich in
solchen klubs das virus unerkannt
verbreitet wenn jemand carola nicht nur
als bier in sich trägt
in stockholm genießen sie die freiheiten
die ihnen der schwäbische sonderweg
lässt auch wenn ihm den klubs hygiene
regeln gelten und nicht mal 20 prozent
der plätze besetzt werden dürfen ich
verstehe dass das für den rest der welt
hier sehr komisch aussieht dass wir
keine masken tragen und dass wir uns
hier draußen bewegen und lachen
aber ich glaube das führt dazu dass es
uns gut geht so gut vielleicht denn
schwedens nachbarn ist so ein lockerer
umgang mit der pandemie nicht geheuer
dänemark finnland und norwegen haben
solche treffen lange nicht zugelassen
und viel weniger abfall zu verzeichnen
zu beginn der feriensaison wollen sie
urlauber aus schweden nicht einreisen
lassen die schweden müssen sich wohl die
sonnenuntergänge im eigenen land
anschauen und das macht schon
kopfzerbrechen dass die freunde in
dänemark norwegen finnland dass sie eben
andere fallzahlen haben und er ist auch
andere vorsichtsmaßnahmen gegenüber den
schweden ergreifen und das stört das
selbstbild der schweden sehr empfindlich
auch für die deutsche kirche in
stockholm gilt wegen krone ein
gottesdienst verbot fahrer weißbach
betreut die gemeinde seit ein paar
jahren und kennt die kehrseite des
schwedischen wegs
im moment zahlen den preis
die älteren das ist ganz deutlich die
hälfte aller todesfälle sind eben aus
diesem bereich der seniorenheime oder
auch durch herrschens also viele
menschen wohnen ja alleine wären dann
immer betreut in einem pflegedienst der
kommt dann drei bis fünfmal am tag und
das sind aber auch wechselnde person und
das ist die haben den preis bezahlt die
verantwortlichen für das schwedische
pandemie konzept haben inzwischen fehler
auf diesem gebiet eingeräumt und wollen
nach steuern
frederik und jessica sind froh dass sich
corona für ihre familie erstmal erledigt
hat vom konzept der herdenimmunität
profitieren sie jetzt habe sie wissen
auch dass andere nicht so gut davon
gekommen sind
in bezug auf unsere senioren haben wir
versagt
da haben wir die todesfälle erlebt und
das ist zutiefst tragisch aber dass wir
jüngeren unser leben einigermaßen normal
leben dürfen ist gut
nach dem sommer wird sich zeigen ob sich
der schwedische sonderweg wenigstens in
teilen bewährt hat und das land von
frederik und seine familie vielleicht
besser durch eine zweite welle der
pandemie kommt als der rest europas